عوده الجمال عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه من جديد هل تتوقعون ان تعودوا
العلاقات بشكل طبيعي مع كافه او عدد كبير
من الدول العربيه
صباح الخير الك ول مشاهدي العربيه اول شيء
سوريا لم تغب عن الجامعه العربيه او عن
العرب لتعود اليهم سوريا حاره دائما
وكلمات
جميع من
الوفود العربيه بالامس تحدثت عن هذا
الحضور الدائم لسوريا في الوجدان العربيه
هناك ظروف
فرضت هذا الشيء
ربما يكون علينا جميعا
اما العوده
لا اعتقد ان المصطلح هو صحيح المهم اليوم
نحن مع بعض هذا هو الوضع الطبيعي علينا
كعرب ان نكون مع بعض لان في ذلك الخلاص
لنا ما شهدته دولنا خلال 12 سنه الماضيه
يثبت هذا الشيء الشرور التي احاطت ببعض
الدول العربيه انعكست على الجميع وبالتالي
انعكست على الواقع العربي كان الواقع
العربي غير صار فاصبح واقعا ماسويا اليوم
اذا اردنا ان نواجه التحديات الكبيره التي
تواجه امتنا والتي تواجه العالم لا خيار
امامنا الا ان نكون مع بعض تحدي التنميه
تحدي الاستقرار تحدي الامن الدفاع عن
حقوقنا الحفاظ على المصالح العربيه ثقي
تماما لا يمكن لاي منا مهما كبر ان يستطيع
التصدي لهذه التحديات بمفرده طيب الجمال
العربيه كانت واضحه فيما يتعلق بمنج خطوه
مقابل خطوه ان تقدم سوريا على خطوات معينه
حتى تعود العلاقات بشكل طبيعي ما الذي
يمكن ان تقدمه سوريا وفقا لهذه القاعده
اول شيء الامور ليست بهذا الشكل ابدا
سوريا اعتقد انها قدمت الكثير وسوريا لا
تزال تقدم الكثير بما يتناسب وتطلعات
شعبها بما يؤدي الى خلود سوريا من هذه
السنوات العجاف نفعل ذلك لانه يحقق مصالح
تتلاشى ابنه ومصالح بلدنا
ان يريد الاخوه العرب رفض جهود سوريا
ومساعدتها على تعزيز الاستقرار وتجاوز
اثار هذه
المحنه هذا شيء مرحب به وهذا ما كنا ننادي
به منذ البدايه لذلك كانت كان احباط وخيبه
السوريين كبيره جدا عندما تعرضوا للارهاب
ولم يجدوا احدا من اخوتهم يمدون اليد
لمساعدتهم اليوم كما يقولون ان تاتي
متاخرا خير من ان لا تاتي ابدا اليوم هناك
ادراك هناك وعي متزايد لضروره تعزيز الامن
والاستقرار في كل الدول العربيه ليس ولكن
تظل الازمه السوريه كما هي تحتاج الى حلول
سياسيه شيء طبيعي هذه الازمه افرزت بعض
المشاكل الكبيره مثل ازمه المهجرين هي
ازمه اولا وقبل كل شيء وليس كما يعتقد
الاخرون هي ازمه لسوريا اولا واخيرا لماذا
لان الخساره الكبيره التي تكبدتها سوريا
جراء هذه الحرب هي خسارتها لكوادرها
المؤهله كوادرها التي غادرت البلاد
وكانت دخلت سوق العمل في البلاد الاخرى
لانها كوادر مؤهله ما هو المطروح فيها
الدوله الكثير ما هو المطروح في اجتماعات
الجامعه فيما يتعلق بملف اللاجئين لهؤلاء
ان يعودوا الى سوريا اعلنا ذلك قبل اكثر
من مره كنا دائما نقول ولا نزال ونكرر
السوري ليس بحاجه الى دعوه للعوده الى
وطنه واحد اثنين الدوله السوريه اتخذت
الكثير الكثير من الاجراءات من اجل توفير
الظروف
لهذه العوده الكريمه والطوعيه لابنائنا
الذين اجبرهم الارهاب والظروف الاقتصاديه
الصعبه على مغادره البلاد لكن هذه العوده
لها متطلبات يعني هؤلاء الذي يريد الذين
يريدون ان يريدون ان يعودوا الى مدنهم الى
قراهم الى منازلهم كيف كيف ستقدمون على
هذه الخطوات وفقا لاجتماعات الجامعه وهو
يمكن ان تدعم هذه الجهود هنا يظهر الترابط
بشكل كبير بين موضوع اعاده الاعمار وعوده
اللاجئين لانه كما ذكرت من يريد ان يعود
الى سوريا يريد ان يعود الى مكان تتوفر
فيه ابسط الخدمات
وتاهيل البنى التحتيه التي تضررت جراء
الارهاب من هنا نقول كيف يمكن ان نقوم
باعاده الاعمار في ظل العقوبات والحصار
والارهاب الاقتصادي الذي تتعرض له سوريا
لذلك علينا جميعا بدل الشهود في هذا
المجال وهذا يثبت مره جديده ان اولئك
الذين فرضوا العقوبات على سوريا ويمارسون
الارهاب الاقتصادي عليها هم من يعيقون
عوده اللاجئين لماذا لانهم يريدون
الاستمرار في استثمار معانات هؤلاء لخدمه
اجنداتهم ولكن ما زالت مواجهات مسلحه ما
زالت هناك ازمه كبيره تحتاج الى حل سياسي
واطار سياسي للتفاوض بعض الاطراف الدوليه
والعربيه ايضا ترى انه لا يتوافر حتى
اللحظه اطار سياسي لحل هذه الازمه من قبل
النظام
اول شيء يجب ان تصححي التعبير من قبل
الحكومه السوريه وليست نظام لانه عندما
تقولي النظام هذا صنفتي نفسك ضمن فئه
معينه ولا اعتقد ان العرب النظام في اي
دوله النظام في
اي تمام هيك اتفقنا البعض ينتظر خطوات
معينه من الحكومه السوريه على صعيد حل
الازمه السياسيه المتعلقه بتلك الماساه
الكبيره التي عاشها الشعب السوري على مدى
السنوات الطويله
انخلطت في هذا الحل تشارك بانتظام ملتزم
اكثر من غيره في اجتماعات اللجنه
الدستوريه التي تعقد في جنيف
انطلاقا من مفهومنا بان هذه العمليه هي
حوار سياسي هي حوار عفوا سوري سوري بقياده
وملكيه سوريه دون اي تدخل خارجي لان اكثر
ما عانيناه في هذه الازمه هو تلك التدخلات
الخارجيه التي هي ابعد ما تكون عن الخدمه
السوريه ومصالح السوريه
الذي راى البعض ايضا انها حققت الازمه
بشكل كبير نتحدث عن الدور الايراني الدوري
التركي
والدور تدميري في سوريا تركيا كانت راس
الحربه في هذا المش على سوريا لذلك على
تركيا التي غدرت بالعلاقه بين البلدين ان
تقوم
بانتاج مقاربه جديده اذا كانت فعلا ما
تقوله صحيح عن انها تريد ان تفعل شيء من
اجل
استقرار الاوضاع في سوريا
الاراده خلال اللقاءات التي يتم الحديث
عنها انها تتم الاتصالات التي يقال انها
تتم اقول لك نعم سمعنا كلاما قويا في هذا
في هذا الشان ولكن الكلام بيبقى مثل
الشيكات على بياض نحن نريد افعال ولا نريد
اقوال عندما الافعال نقول نعم هذا الشيء
الصحيح لكن الاقوال كل يوم يمكننا ان
نتحدث
بالكثير الكثير بالنسبه
للدوله ايران ايران بكل بساطه سوريا تعرضت
لحرب لعدوان ارهابي ارهابيين
[موسيقى]
هو تلك التدخلات الخارجيه في الشان السوري
خدمه لمشاريع تتعلق بالمنطقه او
بالجيوبوليتك في العالم
بمجمله طبعا كل ما خفت هذه التدخلات او
كلما كانت هذه التدخلات دعيني اقول لك
ايجابيه هذا يمكن ان يساعد في تعزيز
الاستقرار في سوريا
وطيها صفحه هذه السنوات المؤلمه هل تتفق
حضرتك معي ان هذا يحتاج الى قرار سياسي
سوري داخلي القرار السياسي السوري الداخلي
متخذ متخذ نحن في الداخل بعد مكافحه
الارهاب
قمنا بالكثير من المصالحات الوطنيه
قمنا باصدار الكثير من مراسيم العفو اخرها
المرسوم سبعه الذي يعتبر لا سابقه له ليس
في سوريا وانما في اي بلد في العالم من
خلال شموليته
ولوجه اشاره للجميع ان الدوله السوريه
تريد ان تطوي هذا الصفحه السوداء وحتى
يعود الجميع الى سوريا حتى يتكاتف الجميع
من اجل اعاده بناء الوطن السوري وتحقيق
الاستقرار في سوريا الاكراد كيف يمكن
التعامل مع هذا الملف في ضوء التطورات
الحاليه او المساعي الحقيقيه لحل هذه
الازمه
من حيث المبدا الاكراد هم جزء لا يتجزا من
النسيج الوطني السوري يعيشون بيننا هم
سوريون سوريون مثل مثل اي سوريه اخر لكن
هناك بعض المتطرفين الاكراد الذين هم
بالاساس وقياداتهم ليست سوريه هم اتوا من
جبال قنديل لهم طلوعات
انفصاليه تتماهى مع المشروع الامريكي في
المنطقه لذلك
المشكله ليست مع الاكراد السوريين المشكله
مع هذا الطرح الانفصالي الذي يشكل تهديدا
لوحده سوريا وهذا الشيء مرفوض جمله
وتفصيلا اي حوار اي تعاطي مع اي سوري لا
مشكله لدينا اما ولكن تحت سقف الوطن
السوري اما ان ياتي البعض الذين هم غرباء
عن سوريا ويريدون ان يفتتوا سوريا ثقه
تماما هذا
لا نصيب له من النجاح اقول لك بصراحه هو
موضوع مزعج ولكنه لا يقلقنا البته ابدا
رغم خطورته لا يقلقنا البته لماذا لانهم
اداه للمشروع الامريكي الامريكي لن يبقى
في سوريا الى الابد وهؤلاء سيسقطون من
تلقاء انفسهم نعم الكل يترقب الكلمه التي
سيلقيها الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد في
الجامعه العربيه بعد 12 عاما من الغياب
كانت اخر قمه في سرت 2010 ما الذي يمكن ان
يحمله الخطاب السياسي للرئيس السوري لا
يمكن ان يكون خطاب السيد الرئيس الا
الخطاب العربي الجامع الخطاب الذي يعبر عن
توجهات السياسه الخارجيه واهميه البعد
العربي في السياسه الخارجيه السوريه
الخطاب الذي يدعو الى تحصين الموقف العربي
الى لم الشمل العربي الى ان نكون جميعا مع
بعض لان في ذلك السبيل الوحيد لمواجهه
التحديات الماسله والراهله ما هي الدول
التي يمكن ان نقول ان العلاقه بينها وبين
سوريا عادت الى طبيعتها بشكل جيد
بصراحه معظم الدول العربيه معظم الدول
العربيه العلاقات معها هناك تواصل هناك قد
تستغربين هناك في سوريا
14 السفاره العربيه تعمل في دمشق يعني
والامور الان
خلال وقت قصير كمان في دول اعربت عن
الرغبه اولها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الاسبوع القادم هناك وفي السعودي سيحدث
الى دمشق من اجل استئناف العمل في السفاره
السعوديه في دمشق
وبالمقابل السفاره السوريه في الرياض
الامور تسير بشكل جيد علاقاتنا مع الجميع
جيده
[موسيقى]
يوجد ربما لا يزال لا تزال مشكله مع
الاخوان القطريين
نتركهم لوحدهم هل تعتقد ان هذه القمه
قادره على اذابه بعض الخلافات مع الجانب
السوري والجانب القطري
لذلك مع عوده هذه العلاقات وهذه الاجواء
الايجابيه الجديده في العمل العربي
باعتقد التبادل الزياره شيء طبيعي يعني
بين كل الدول
دكتور هل تعتقد حضرتك ان الحديث عن فكره
الصفقات السياسيه فيما يتعلق
بالازمه السوريه انتهى هذا العهد ام انه
يمكن ان يكون وارد في اي مرحله لاحق والله
شفت مثل هذه الصفقات بل بورصه خاصه كثير
بعد ما تحقق في سوريا ما بعتقد حدا عادي
يقدر يستثمر بهيك مشاريع مشاريع سياسيه
السياسيه لانه تكلف ماديا الكثير ليس
ماديا تكلف ماديا وتكلف
تاريخيا ومن سمعته وسوريه بقيت شكرا مع
الوزير على هذا اللقاء شكرا اهلا بك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات